[Music]
can you cheat your way into ketosis
the answer is yes and though I've been
asked a lot recently about different
ketone supplements exhaustion Asst
ketones all right these are externally
synthesized ketones that you can consume
often in liquid form a good way to
remember exhaustion is EXO like
exoskeleton outside endogenous that
would be ketones produced in the body
for instance if you fast and then eat
one meal per day for two or three days
like a salad with a little bit of steak
and a bunch of oil and you walk a lot
during that period of time drinking
water chances are in two or three days
especially if you're a male typically
drop in faster they'll probably get to
0.7 or higher millimolar of
beta-hydroxybutyrate
bhp as measured using a device called
the precision extra x-tra by abbott labs
which is what i use and i recommend
people use something like that with
blood as opposed to your analysis with
the keto sticks which as you get better
at processing ketones in your body will
give you a false negative it will say
you're not in ketosis but let's come
back to the exhaustion of ketones a lot
of my friends have said hey have you
seen this have you seen that seems like
I could just consume this to get the
benefits of ketosis while I'm consuming
my normal diet and there is some
evidence to suggest that you can derive
certain benefits say relate to
anti-inflammation
or otherwise by consuming exogenous
ketones even in the presence of
carbohydrates however and I'm not a
doctor don't play one on the internet
but I suspect at least that more
research should be done related to the
longer term say for a few weeks
consumption of exogenous ketones while
you are eating a normal carbohydrate
dependent diet when you're using still
glucose is your primary fuel the only
place in nature as it relates to human
physiology that I'm aware of
where you observe both elevated glucose
levels and elevated ketone levels is in
a state called ketoacidosis which is a
dangerous state observed typically I
believe in type 1 diabetics so if then
we are mimicking that by consuming
exogenous ketones on a regular basis
it's hard for me to see how that is
beneficial and strikes me as somewhat
epistemologically arrogant as Nassim
Taleb might say for us to believe with
the limited data we have that that is a
good idea I would prefer to be
conservative and I am conservative
personally in that respect ocular sticky
tones can be a fantastic tool for
greasing the skids and helping with the
transition from say a semi fasted or
fasting state perhaps you're using
intermittent fasting like I mentioned to
consume one or two small meals a day
that are ketogenic diet meals on route
to ketosis you can use the exhaustion as
ketones to give you some firepower and
actual cognitive ability in that
normally very gray zone until you click
in and get to say 0.7 1.2 1.5 millimolar
at which point you'll be off to the
races
but otherwise I've decided for myself
that I generally steer away from it that
doesn't mean that for instance if you
have depressed glucose levels and you've
just come off of a nice big sleep and
you had an early dinner the night before
perhaps in those circumstances if you
are about to do exercise say aerobic
exercise you could use ketones to
enhance performance but caveat emptor I
would say be careful and as far as I'm
concerned to be conservative
you